con thank you um so just to mention I'm
French I'm not Italian okay and my name
is my name is Ser and not Roberto
Roberto is my family name okay but I'm
very happy to work with Italian people
so
uh um so let me start with the
model
so we will consider the tree so let me
draw the bar tree but it could be
regular car
tree so all along the to K will be just
two but all the result will hold for for
General key so um so this is a threee
and I will consider spin system so I
have configuration the state space is
just 01 to the
T and given
a configuration is in Omega and X in
t um Sigma of
X is either zero or one so if it's one I
would say that the site site
X site X is
filled or there is a
particle at X and uh if uh there the the
the configuration that X is zero I would
say that X is
empty okay
so um so we have zero and
ones and um so we would like to run a
Dynamics on on on this and so the
Dynamics is is as follows each each side
we minan one exponential time in
independently and when the the the the
the ring clocks um the clock rings some
at some point so say here the the site
look at the children the two children
and uh you ask for both children to be
empty to make an update okay so in that
case this guy will do nothing this guy
will will do the update okay and what is
the update you just forget about the
configuration at the site so you forget
about the zero and with probability P
you put a one with probability one minus
P which I would call Q you put a zero
okay and again if if one of the two
children is one or two children are one
you don't do anything so the the
generator of this uh of these Dynamics
is is the following so you CH the sum of
all site in in the in the tree and
uh so then you put
the equilibrium respect to abandoning
measure so this depends on
Sigma so let me write this
again okay so mux is just a
b b measure
so p is some
parameter is infinite for the moment it
will be finite later on but for now it's
infinite
okay so and what is CX of Sigma so CX is
the constraint it's either one or zero
so it's one if
all the children of X are empty
and zero
otherwise okay is it clear for everybody
the the
Dynamics so again each side wait a Mean
One exponential time when the C the ring
CL the clock rings you look at the
children and both must be empty to to do
a an
update okay so as probably you already
guessed the more one you have in the
system and the the the slower the system
is right and in particular if you look
at the the your tree if you start with
all ones the dynamic Will Never Move at
all okay and uh also if you want to if
you want to change something at this
point you will first wait to put some
zero here and here and so you have to go
down and look for the first first line
of zero you can find and and go up yes
do you it doesn't move the bottom guy
move uh well the the tree is infinite so
okay at some point it will be finite and
we will put some boundary condition
which will be empty
but so it's infinite okay so
um uh so the the the dynamic L is uh is
symmetric in L2 of of mu where mu is
just the product product measure of B
measure okay so here the contrary to the
eing model or this kind of model
statistical model where the the the
measure itself is is hard to to handle
with here the measure is just the
product measure so the I mean the
problem are coming from the dynamic
itself not from the measure there is no
static actually
okay so the the issue the problem is
uh uh
understand the long
time
Behavior okay so maybe again if
Q is
small the
dynamic is slowed down
um okay so a bit of history about this
this
model so as it is this this has been
introduced by aldus
andonis
2002 where um they were actually dealing
with another model called the e this
model which is a one diens one
dimensional model they they computed the
spectral gap of the such such a model
and uh um I will say that in in a minute
the this this is part of a a more
General class of of model called
kinetically constraint model so there is
this one one dimensional model which is
the E model but there is also a two-
dimensional model which is the Northeast
model so you do the same each side of
the grid wait some exponential time and
when when you want to do an update you
look at the East and the north neighbor
and you ask for both of them to be empty
so they introduced this model as a kind
of uh to model for for this North
Northeast okay because we are on the
tree so things should be
easier
um okay so as I said um so the model is
part the model is
part of larger
family of kally constrainted models so
this this
model uh has been introduced by
physicist in the
80s um in order to to model the liquid
liquid glass transition so the idea
behind this transition is is that the
glass the glass transition might be only
a dynamical transition so if you take
your liquid and you slow down the
temperature very quickly the the the
move of the particle cannot cannot occur
easily and so you cannot uh reach a
crystal or some homogeneous structure so
your liquid just is is just um stuck in
some in some erogeneous uh uh situation
which is called uh amorphus solid and
this is supposed to be the the glass so
this this systems here this this family
uh we exactly devised to mimic this this
phenomena um and uh so this is the point
the in order to make a move you need
space so you need empty sides and you
have some block structures okay like the
as I said all ones is blocked
forever so let me say maybe a few names
here if you want to go for the
literature
um so if you're interested
in so there are many others if if you're
interested there these two guys they
they did some survey in
2003 about this this this kind of these
models
um
okay
so so let's introduce some some map the
boostrap map that I will use later
on uh so there is a classical result
that says that the two the two assertion
are equivalent so zero is a
simple gain
value of
L
and DF of
Sigma so Sigma T is the evolution of the
the process time T this converges to Mu
of f where mu is the product ver measure
in
L2 for all F in
L2 so there is
Convergence okay
so um so let me introduce some PC which
will be just the supremum of all
P such that zero is a
simple again value of
L and uh we would like to understand
what is exactly this quantity so for
that I will introduce the boostrap
map can I a question yes maybe you said
this so you have two stationary distribs
and the point at all on actually there
are many of them that's what's going
besides compex combinations you still
have many others yeah yeah you any Les
infinite lesser will be stacked so you
can you know you can invent a lot of of
uh block configurations so the point is
if you start from
mu then depending on the parameter P you
will have clusters or not so actually
this the bootp map will just give you
this but probably you already guessed if
if you are below 1 half things will be
fine for you because the Clusters will
be just finite if if you are above 1
half you will find an infinite cluster
and so you're not a goic at
all so let me say that in properly so
the Boost map is a determinist
deterministic map so from a
configuration in the in my in my state
space
I I have a new
configuration um which is as follow so
uh this is
zero so the bootp map just uh want you
to have zeros okay so you look at your
configuration if you have a zero you
just keep the the zero so it's zero
if Sigma of X is
zero but also if the
original uh your Dynamics wanted to put
a zero or you're allowed to put a zero
so so if the constraint is
satisfied like here well here now okay
like here the this guy so you also put a
zero okay and you don't do anything for
the rest so if the constant is satisfied
or you already uh is a zero you you you
you put a zero so if
or uh c x of Sigma is
one
okay so you can look at the at the low
starting from mu after an iteration of
this map so I will call this mu
n and um uh it's possible to prove that
actually this mu n converges to some mu
Infinity I think probably the the first
to show that
was and uh so now I can Define another
quantity so boost percolation shold
which which would be the supremum of all
P such that with probability one say the
root so C
of the root is
zero so if you look if you look at your
you start with a configuration given by
me okay then you apply the bootstrap map
uh infinitely many times and you ask
that the the root is empty at the end of
this procedure okay this with
probability
one okay so actually you can prove
so this is a result by Martinelli
and I should say that so there is two
tonelli like Chris two brother and
sister in that case so this is Christina
ton and not Fabio T so it's the it's the
girl
so using some technique of the four of
us on on on different mod mod do so they
adapt the technique to the to the tree
you can prove that both uh
critical quantity actually equals and
they both equal one2 because of this
quantity here is just the the the when
do you know that the the root is not
empty at the end of the Boost STP it it
must be part of a an infinite cluster
okay so so this this quantity is not
known to be one2 and what you you can
prove is the two quantity
equals so more generally it's one / K if
you are looking at
kry So Below 1
half uh you have this convergence here
and above you don't
okay so we' like to understand maybe a
bit
better um what's going on in the
long uh time Behavior
so um I will talk about spectral Gap
spectral Gap produce
this so if I call the directly form of
of a function which is Mu of f minus mu
of is just the sum of all X in
t
so this is the directly
form uh the gap of my operator L is just
the infinum of all F which are not
constant maybe I should say here uh zero
is the again value Associated to
constant functions if you take constant
function here you get zero
okay so you want to
so is the directly
form and the
variance so why is interesting to look
at this quantity because so a way to
restate that is just to say that for any
F you have this quantity and actually
this is exactly equivalent to the fact
that the
variance of
PTF is less than exponential
2T the spectral Gap the variance new of
f so in particular there is no hope to
to get such a result above 1 half there
is no spectral Gap
and
um
uh um probably I should write it
again
all depend on Sigma so
U um since you don't have any spectral
Gap you can try to look at the system on
finite size so now are coming finite
tree so take a a tree of depth uh
L
L then you want the system to be aric so
here you have the the boundary you just
put all zero
here so in other word the constraint
here at that sides are always
satisfied okay so I will change the the
generator l in L sub L which exactly the
same but now I have new
constraint which is the same as before
except that on the boundary the
constraint is always
satisfied okay so this this guy here uh
equals that one except on the boundary
where it's always
one so you can Define again the the Gap
uh inside this system so let me call it
Gap
gap of
L
one
okay
um so now comes the the conjecture by
alus andonis about the spectral
Gap
so here in that case the the inant
measured is is just the product measure
on the the fin entry
so
conjecture so the conjecture is the
following uh if p is less
than2
then the
gap of l
l is just a constant
uniformly in
L in other word the Gap over there is
just
constant
so if P equals 12 so at
criticality the
Gap
um so here is the
conjecture the Gap should be uh 1 / l
squ so order of 1 / l
s Pol and if p is larger than
12 then the
Gap should be exponential
sorry or
something okay so here is the
picture so one and three actually
um uh are part of the paper here so one
and three are proved in one and
three
addressed in
uh so what I would like to talk about is
is um this
result that
criticality
sorry well I mean bounded above and
below by some constant times this well
we don't we don't have this
result it's it's too much what we have
is this so here is the
term so uh fix P = 12
um then there exist some some uh Power
beta
positive such
that for any
K so remember we we took k equal 2 but
it's all for any K there exist some C
that depends on K and beta search
that uh the gap
is in
between um 1 / L 2 + beta so constant
constant of
L here is the result we
get uh so this is the first first
result the second is a Ki critical case
sorry oh so K so uh at the beginning I
said we can we can deal with the K tree
instead of the B
tree is it
still it's one over K so yes okay so
let's say let's forget about K so there
exist beta and C such
that but you could just
as yes yes yes yes but I don't want to
confuse any yeah yeah no you're right
okay we can you have the result with any
K and maybe this is important because
the constant beta does not depend on
K I wanted to emphasize that and uh so
now fix P less than PC so one over one
over two so then again
so I don't remember it's maybe it's beta
+ one so then there exist some
constant two
constant such
that the
gap of the infinite system
now behaves like constant time P minus
pc/
two and P minus
PC 2 + Alpha
two or
three
yes
so uh yes PC minus
P so when you approaches the the
critical point you you do it in a a poal
way okay I will I will not prove that I
will try to give some some
uh idea of the proof of this uh but just
before
that so remember what is the boot trp
map because I will use
it
let me mention two papers that are
related to that so related
papers so one is by
umy D
luety and and
newp so I don't know I don't
know 11 probably
okay so here they are dealing with the
eing
model on three so the same as us at
criticality and they prove more or less
the same type of reason so there exist a
constant beta that does not depend on K
such that this this is true
so again um here the difficulties coming
from the measure so the static of the
measure not not the Dynamics right here
for us the the measure is is easy but
the dynamic is difficult and uh there is
also paper by luety
and and
Sly
2012 so they are dealing with the eing
model
add
criticality on
Z2 so again they are proving some polom
decay of the of the spectral Gap in
finite
boxes okay um
so let me go from some words of the
proof so I would just prove one maybe
say something about two but very short
so proof of
one so the proof goes uh us this
multiscale
analysis plus uh some
um
auxiliary long
range
Dynamics so some comparison
argument
probably I will just
okay okay
so
um H
yes yes just before so the the upper
bound uh as usual you just try to find a
test function you you so the upper bound
of upper
bound we use a test function
so what you use is the you take the F of
Sigma which which is just the number of
of s that are attached to the occupied
cluster of ones to the root okay so the
number the
number of
sides of the
cluster
attached
to the
root so here is the
root so you have some ones maybe more
than one maybe this one is zero and so
on and uh so since you're dealing with
the tree actually you can compute more
or less everything so um this function
you can prove that this is greater than
constant time l to the
cube and uh so here is one of the
Gap that you are looking for directly
form and uh what is the directly form so
one over the
Gap is just the sum of all X in the tree
of length of depth L mu of
CX but now
how can this be different from from zero
you just need to to make a move just on
the leaves of the cluster if you're not
on the leaf of one leaf you you cannot
do any move so this will be zero so this
is just less than some
constant X is a leave
of the
cluster which is bounded by just the the
measure of the cluster
itself mu of F and this you can compute
is just proportional to L so you
get the upper bound so for the lower
bound you use this uh M scale
analysis so let let me go for that
um okay
so let me call Little L
just something that will be a little
bit smaller than capital L and uh so it
will be some depth and uh I introduce a
new con constraint cxl
Sigma which is
one if I can do the following so X is
here what I ask I look below
X so I will just need to go uh till dep
uh
L and I ask if I use I use the boot trp
map L minus time l l times or maybe l l
minus one times I can empty the two guys
here okay so it's one
if the the the true
constraint of the bootstrap map applied
l l minus one * of Sigma is
one so in other word if if uh uh using L
times the Boost I can put two zero
here okay so somehow
this just uh show you that somewhere in
the original configuration you have some
line of zero here that you can use and
with less than L steps you can put two
zero here L steps of the bootp M okay so
you speed up uh very quickly the
Dynamics by that the usual Dynamics is
you you have for two Z here you ask for
something much stronger to have a line
somewhere
okay
so uh and also the the probability and
the me that this did not
happen so you can compute that
explicitly and it's uh of order 2 over l
so I will use it say it's small but it's
uh it would be very
useful uh okay
so so is the first LMA actually the only
one I will
prove so probably if you're tired it's a
good point to start to
sleep because now until some technical
technical I I'm afraid it will be a bit
hard to to follow so please interrupt me
or just sleep whatever you
like so LMA is the
variant will be less than some constant
which depend on the Dela so Delta at the
end will be small well Delta is just
some parameter between Z and
one so your three of depth L and here so
you have your Dynamics
but so let me explain what it
is uh
F so what is t t hat X is uh so you have
your big tree here so this is the the
big Tre of depth L you have some point x
okay and so T hat is just the three
below X without X okay so without X this
is t t x
okay
um uh what I should say also about this
constraint since on the boundary you
have all Zer here and because of the the
the choice of small
L if you are below uh some
line which is so this is Delta L okay if
you are below this line the constraint
will be satisfied okay so all the side
below CX is just one
deterministically okay this is clear for
everybody because of the zero here you
know that the boot trp map will will
just give you two zero uh as
children uh okay so so this is one thing
and uh I need something different so
this is T at X and So Below X I also use
uh the following notation I call Delta X
just the small threee that that that is
below X at and of that L small
L uh okay yeah so what's the LMA says
somehow it says that uh you can you have
some some kind of uh spectral Gap
inequality not for the usual Dynamics
but with this one with a with a constant
which is just a constant and this will
help us at the end because this will
guarantee that below X you can find this
line of zero then you will try to apply
some comparison argument
so if I have time I will say just a few
words so how do you prove this
LMA so I want to prove this LMA because
uh here we use very much the fact that
this this is a tree and we are Tri
criticality uh using this fact okay this
is the the main thing
we it's true for entropy sorry do you
know the Lama is true for
entropy um no actually we
tried uh well I don't know if if it's
not true but uh what I know if we don't
know if it's
true now we try you you'll see we we do
some crude argument like you
know uh that you cannot do with the
entrop because of X log X
business so proof of the
Lima so the starting point is is a is an
easy
fact so what is true is
this so it would be
new so this is just using repeatedly the
conditional equality for the viance this
is this is easy it's not not there is
nothing deep
here um and then what you do you just
you you just insert here this the
constraint you want to insert and the
complement so here you had this uh
constraint plus uh the
complement and you use just you know the
vant so this is less than two * the sum
of what you
want so this is what you want at the End
plus something that you would like to
control so what we would like to do is
to control this guy
all this sum by a constant less than one
times this sum okay this is our
objective so this is what we want at the
end and uh we just want to bring that on
the other side of the inequality
and okay
so
um how do you do that so let me take one
one of this this
guy
so already at this step uh pro at this
step you cannot do anything with the the
entropy well maybe you you need to be a
bit
more flavor and do something else I
don't know but uh our approach does it
work uh so I take one of these guy and
try to to deal with so the viance x of
um so I just choose that this is less
than the second moment so mu I can
reconstruct TX
here mu X
whatever
but uh
since since
CX this constraint depends only on the
on on this small the small tree Delta
X um I can bring Bring It Outside The
this mean so here there is
um
so this because this guy here depend
only on what is inside Delta X okay so I
can bring it outside this this m this me
now I use kosi Schwartz with respect to
this measure
I bring the square inside and at this
point the the the the measure of this
guy is just the the constant two over l
i so some constant over
L time mux
of mu
TX s
but if you take the proper normalization
you can from the beginning ask F to to
have mean zero respect to this measure
so this is nothing
but the variance sorry
mu the
variance d
x of of this
guy
so you gain something because of this
quantity that is
small and um so now I use this
inequality here but not on the complete
on the the worldall three just on the on
the small 3tx okay I use it again so I
get constant of L the sum of all y that
are in TX
but this quantity does not depend on
what is outside Delta X so you what you
exactly need is what is in Delta x uh an
X of the
variance so there is a
mux of the variance y of
mu of f so I'm using just this
inequality but inside the small 3 TX
so we are almost done now I just take
the sum so I'm back here so let me call
this
guy I so I will be less than two times
what we we
need so this is the good
guy plus 2 * so 2 c/ n the sum of our
all X and the sum of our all
y's of mu of the MU TX so there is a mu
outside
um i
y so now I just have to in the two
sum when I change the sum what happens
is now I want to to sum of all
Y and uh to count how many X I have so
fix a
y so you fix a y
somewhere and you ask how many X you
have such that the Delta X contains Y
and actually you have uh at most Delta L
of them so the one that are above the
the the one I mean the the F ground F so
at the end you get two times the good
quantity
so inverting the sum plus 2 * c l *
Delta L and here you get again the the
quantity on the
left so now L is 1 minus Delta capital L
there is this Delta here so you take
Delta small enough you bring this on the
other part and you get get the
Lima
okay so this ends up actually of the
Lima so you see we used um very much the
fact that
um uh we had this quantity
here
maybe I want to say that
so um here is an open question so look
at the system where you where you have
so it's uh
three3 but you don't ask now the dynamic
is is not you ask all the children to be
empty but you you ask just two of them
at least two of them to be empty in
order for for this guy to to make a a
flip you ask that two of them whatever
the order are empty okay and you ask the
same question so here you can prove that
the bo map all these business holds the
the critical value is 8 over
9 and uh you ask what what happens at
critical points okay but here the the
picture is very different
because uh with probability 3 over four
with positive probability there is an
infinite
cluster so there is an INF cluster of
one why here the cluster of one with
probability two two L with with high
probability you don't have a cluster
larger longer than than L okay so the
picture is very different
here okay so so again in in the proof we
use very much this fact so for this
problem we don't know how to
do so this is an open
question
uh
okay so this was the first step of the
of the
proof how many time do I have it's over
I know that's
fine no actually no I come from the
Middle East we can negotiate no no
no I'm fine I I wanted to I wanted to
show you that I mean the the the
the last part of the proof actually I
just wanted to do it by hand so that is
just warming up
now you just
arrived no so the the so the second part
step two which I will not do
precisely is this kind of M multiscale
analysis so now this this this
constraint somehow gives you the I mean
the guarantee that you have some line of
zero here somewhere so what you would
like we like you you want to do is
to
um what uh to consider the system
instead of looking at the variance at
site X you just increase the the your
set and you look at the at the set that
arrives till the border the right border
gra guaranteed by this guy so once you
have the good border you can apply the
spectral Gap that you know uh is
something okay but uh you you you have
this on scale l so you can divide the
scale l in various you know height so
let me maybe write the one
intermediate step
two so what could what you can prove
after that is that the sum which is on
the right hand side
here no sorry bance
X
um is less than some constant times so
there will be the sum of one to n or nus
one
maybe
so what is TI T is just the inverse of
the spectral
gap of um your your operator but for
trees of length so Alpha is some
parameter greater than
one and so you have different scale okay
you will take like capital L to be Alpha
to the say n + 1
one okay you choose Delta so that L this
small L is Alpha to the
end okay and so at the end you you can
prove something of this type that you
can at the
end um by
induction just
um solve and prove the result so again
the idea is you divide
the your um your size small l in various
size of size Alpha to the I and once you
have the line of zero somewhere say it's
a distance Alpha to the I but not at
distance Alpha to the I + one or
something like that then uh or the
converse it's at this distance but not
that one then you enlarge the variance
in order to get the the good boundary
condition then you apply the spectral
Gap at this level with some monotonicity
it will gives you this TI well you have
to play a little bit and you get you get
the result so it's probably better to
stop here thank
you questions
comments I was wondering if the cluster
attached to the wood yes is itself Mar
starting from you start from
from you you consider the the set given
by the cluster yes I have the impression
that it is
mar this one because when you will
attach the problem is sometimes you will
attach another cluster but this one you
don't nothing about
it so I was wondering you
consider b as of Gap the number of the
point inside but I think maybe something
more subtile than that forc Conant ass
comparison with the number of leave and
total number of the ah but uh okay but
it should be true actually L Square
should be the right
answer so
so yes because maybe be a comparison
with this cluster is
evolution with a evolving set forance if
you forid to to attach auster but just
just put one remove one on the
B maybe there could be a
comp but the cluster shouldn't be more I
mean the cluster if if you have a big
cluster and then breaks but theer at the
origin because
otherwise but don't you know don't you
have some information Two Step later
that there's a good chance that it will
connect again and and you know and
become large again so suppose you have a
big cluster that you know so so there's
some memory right from like two
steps ago that you can you know jump to
what it was before
maybe more
questions I have question
sorry do you know if uh in fact you
don't lose already something important
at the
first uh yes yes probably we are losing
but uh okay I mentioned the paper but
I'll do they doing this one
dimensional case and uh so in 2008 the
four of us we proved we reprove the same
result their result but also that
includes many of the kin con models
including the two dimensional ones like
Northeast Etc prove that there is a
spectral Gap but uh the the approach is
again kind of multiscale analysis but uh
it doesn't work for the
tree and uh so we had to to to use this
this approach actually this approach was
in the paper by Martinelli slair and
right so they use something like that so
we we we don't have any I mean we don't
have another option for that probably we
are losing a lot but uh I mean be for
kind of functions and of the
number
like but not not for the kind of
function that use for yes you you would
like to have something more tight in
order to get a better bet the end I know
maybe if you lose everything here yes
yes okay let's thank the speaker
again problem session in 16 minutes if
you have a question please hand me a
piece of paper with your name and just a
pap